[Music]
have you guys ever been in an extremely
yes Gary yes uber drive no oh no I won't
wait like I know this guy's no [ __ ] me
or this guy's driving yes Armenian Vin
Diesel you didn't scare me we just want
a t miles an hour [ __ ] trance the
whole time scare me why is it right why
should we zl-- the Armenian Vin Diesel
I'm a mean Vin Diesel ok I thought you
made a children's book out of it I've
been in situations where I feel
uncomfortable for the driver because
they're scared of me and I have no
reason to be threatening are you sure
you're not projecting no because I went
one time I had a red-eye flight not a
red light but like walking early in the
morning right like 4:00 a.m. so I went
down to the lobby and then a lady pulled
up and it's just like hi Joel you want
to sit next to me and I was like ok and
then I got in and she's like ok relax
and I was like oh [ __ ] I didn't know I
was being anxious and she goes yeah
you're kind of freaking me out
and I'm all like well she's on drugs and
I was like ok no III just think that she
was kind of on edge and then there's
another time when then like a lady
pulled up and it you like hey hey you
want to sit in the front instead of the
back and I was like ok and then she was
asking Matt questions and [ __ ] and I was
like man I feel like they're like
screening me or like making sure that
I'm not gonna do some creepy [ __ ] or
whatever and I'm all like leave me alone
I just want to listen to music alright
yeah dude I had a [ __ ] uber driver
you know I liked it I liked to kinda
interview Mary verdurous was very fun
like because they're very interesting
people usually and they always have some
stories and so it's like I always try to
ask like you know what's the most
fucked-up [ __ ] you've experienced as an
uber driver and this one guy I almost
wish I'd never asked it he's like I
picked up a like a hotshot producer guy
he brought like 14 and 15 year old girls
in the car like the hat could not have
been 18 when they're very young and then
we I drove them to a very building that
everyone would know if I said it out
loud right now
and I'll tell you guys off-camera and
then that I know if he was grabbed on
their asses
and making out with him in the car all
the [ __ ] and like it was very clear that
they were all going to go [ __ ] their oh
they're gonna go [ __ ] in the building
guys no way
why do you v so how many people at that
building know what's going on are down
with it
alright used to there is an elite
celebrity pedophile ring that was ran by
a certain fellow called mr. Epstein he's
like Enoch he didn't kill himself
you know he killed he killed himself
that's what the media formats what the
media says about it otherwise it's a
conspiracy tell you this story
this Hoover driver in Virginia has been
charged after he pulled some crazy [ __ ]
so I will show you a video and what do
you do fart Nicole video No so this is a
life livestream video of the two writers
trying to get this uber driver to stop
so here we go okay so so look what
they're calling it over in she's talking
to the 9-1-1 operator she's telling them
that they had initially gotten hit and
then that's when they started
live-streaming because this blooper
driver started chasing the guy who who
rear-ended him so is he mad at the uber
driver or are they trying to catch the
person that did a hit-and-run
so the uber driver is disregarding the
riders request to get out of the cart
and uber drivers trying to catch this
guy who rear-ended her going through a
shits on a red light it's like it's
raining today Jesus he's like sorry I
got a dark job to do I'm a detective
I need justice hey no it's okay he hit
me
let's race is for hey man four stars now
pal okay hey we're going down one stalk
for every 30 minutes of this so then
they get
he's the guy that hit me oh my god oh my
god yeah yeah okay oh they didn't even
show the guy this is the guy
he's like I don't give a [ __ ] that's
what he looks like he said you could
take down my color but you cannot take
away my new tag you actually couldn't
take down his collar look it's still
you're gonna take the [ __ ] out of me for
a couple passes later it was like I had
four kids please let me out I don't know
what I would have done cuz the first
thing in my mind is pull out my belt
choke the mother you're gonna die I
rather [ __ ] die in my own hands the
first thing I would have done is reached
offering up all the ebrake no so the guy
was saying that he was afraid to touch
him or do anything cuz he didn't want he
don't want the driver to hit pedestrians
or even like - yeah right no matter what
I pull the e brake as soon as the car
stops and get out with her and that's it
well that's best laid plans ain't it
isn't it nice to sit here and watch that
and judge it and everybody's not a
Marine who knows how to do stuff like
and photos gotta [ __ ] pull the e
brake up hey but listen I'm sure it like
you can't pull the e brake up and I do
try to do some stuff like Bart knows a
move I would get my legs around the
vehicles judge him you just say you're
gonna take off your [ __ ] body choke
your diet your whole [ __ ] it's faster
they literally got hit anyway so they
happen at the two hits is like
[ __ ] yeah I don't know what to
do I would just be I would be so crazy
don't you miss out of his head real
quick not some sense that's how I would
have gone like maybe like like try to
knock them out with your phone but again
if you get [ __ ] out and maybe goes
boom into another car you get charged
for assault yeah yeah because in your
line that's true but it wasn't assault
it would be like it'll be self-defense
because if this person won their keys
kidnapping in any time you been hell to
get some wheel just kidnapping yeah it
could also be assault with a uh it could
be via vehicular assault because what if
you if you driving that fast and erratic
he could potentially kill himself and
then are you not liable though for the
person that because of your actions gets
all that's uh I don't know this
assurance company is because know cuz
lawyers could make that case of you if I
choked him out with a belt and then he
ran over like a person if you choke
lining it the girlfriend's liveing
everything oh he was the guy was yeah
I'm not gonna choke him up
can we see the couple again I'll scream
how come he couldn't open the door bro
they were going like 4050 miles every
red light but then since it's raining
your side you can make a red you're
still gonna die
but you're risking German iron man joke
I definitely had three iron man jokes
ready I'm not going I was thinking of
iron man Joe how come he didn't he
didn't channel iron man spirit she
didn't Channel [ __ ] spirit she should
have well that's Beethoven Watson she
wanted this situation she came out of
life what was his that again in Richmond
Virginia so he did get two counts of
abduction reckless driving and felony
hit-and-run he is in custody his license
is gone yeah his freedom is gone right
now somebody hit and run him though
where's the justice
you know license plate for the other the
other driver I was on the five south
headed to the 110 I was about to go to a
show so I'm at I'm at the five I'm at
the five South right baggage by the zoo
right that's all I'm hated soft and
about to get on the one I mean the 110
like right here I'm all right here and
all of a sudden it's [ __ ] Lexus zips
past me and then it's like Honda Pilot
is they kill us I thought they were
racing at first but the way this Lexus
is cutting and that pilot is just right
on him the whole time I thought oh no
like he wants to get back like this is
like obviously a road rage situation
something like but like because they are
like this is around 7:30 so the traffic
is still thick and not mean they are
whipping through traffic on my own so am
I gonna die
for sure for sure for sure they continue
soft I get on the one team take the 110
to the 10 I'm headed back this way and
it's a LaBrea right going to 56 I'm
going get to like Western right and then
I'm looking around here like let's see I
see this in my hair like I mean in my
rear view mirror these fools have made
it to the team that means they took the
5 all the way to the 10 and they'll
still rate that racing but chasing each
other this
this point is like 30 minutes in right
and the only thing I'm thinking is like
who the [ __ ] can afford that much gas
thank you who the [ __ ] follow the
story except for LA people with three
different highways and they were still
owes a friendly race
no I'm telling you Lexus the Lexus was
trying to get away from how were they
did at 6:05 I used to like to do
friendly races frankly what is the thing
if they were racing if they were racing
then the pilot wouldn't have been behind
him he would have been trying that yeah
how did the pilot catch up to such a
fast car I do that love me because it's
still heavy traffic so he didn't they
want they clearly weren't going faster
than like 70 miles so pilot can do 270
man if it lasted that long I'm thinking
do you think it might have been linking
relators something they're trying to run
away from their life I have I have to
chase somebody down for almost hitting
me like I was I was chased them down I
absolutely did in Glendale I was getting
I was moving Christ to have multiple
cars that the house saw almost hitting
you man I was in the car
no I was giving in my vehicle so I
opened the door I was putting a bag in
there for the next morning and I was as
I was about to give me a close the door
as car-like zips past me or [ __ ] but
he's like close like almost Clips me and
I'm like oh you crazy so I hopped
another car that I was already in and I
chase him and he makes a left and I make
a left but I make I'm on her like I'm on
the side of traffic get us suppose we're
going outside the racks on the 10 going
up to 5 no no no just some streets in
the Glendale I cut them out I was like
bro you almost hit me I mean I need that
get out the car
let's handlers right now let me get the
faith he goes around his girls in the
car so now he's zipping through we
headed toward the 134 we get on the 135
Easter Wes Easter West East Pasadena are
the 101 so so we I officially lost them
but I all the smoke I hear you man cuz
it's not even you know there are gangs
in LA a lot of them and so I was on the
floor
there was a guy I caught a guy who's
from the five gang he's on the 405 but I
was like no no no no this is Archer you
get on your [ __ ] you get on the
[ __ ] 101 at least get the [ __ ] off of
my 405 right is appalled by this that's
ten lanes altogether we're hardcore
gonna give a [ __ ] okay
you don't say buckle to ten thank you
say that [ __ ] again say that [ __ ] again
and watch me come over this table no no
no seriously [ __ ] the 210 brother
[Music]